[Musique]
ça s'appelle la forêt des milles
l'écureuils c'est ce qu'on appelle un
parc à bout donc c'est une surface de
plus de 1000 mètres carrés c'est inspiré
de fil catamaran pour partir c'est
défilé tendus et du coup qui donne un
effet très rebondissant huit modules des
passerelles voilà qui permettent
d'accéder à différents modules et
ensuite il y a deux sorties par les
toboggans ou alors pour ceux qui sont
pas trop téméraires ils peuvent repartir
par là où ils sont rentrés
[Musique]
c'est une structure qui s'adresse à tout
public donc à partir du moment où on a
quatre ans on peut y aller accompagner
des adultes c'est familial l'objectif de
partager des souvenirs ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on voulait nous c'était mettre
en valeur la forêt et c'est vrai que ce
sentiment se rapprocher au plus proche
de l'arbre de grimper voilà en quelque
sorte à l'intérieur il y a plein de
panneaux des petits supports pédago qui
parle des arbres des animaux qui peut
plus la forêt donc c'est aussi une
manière sensibiliser à ce sujet là
[Musique]